when russia's sergey lavrov arrived at
the g20 foreign ministers meeting his
host indonesia's retinal marsudi greeted
him warmly
members of the media were not as
welcoming this gathering marks the first
time g20 foreign ministers have met
since russia invaded ukraine
and the war has dominated the meetings
lavrov accused his western counterparts
of russophobia and said they are
deliberately not looking for common
ground on economic issues
no it was not us
who abandoned all contacts it was the
united states
that's all i can say ukraine invited as
a special guest by indonesia has accused
russia of deliberately starving the
world by disrupting supply chains
it says it's futile to talk about food
and energy security without calling for
accountability
it's just direct blackmailing of the
world with a
starvation with a famine
which is inhuman which is cruel and
which is which doesn't meet any
principles of humanity and any
principles of peaceful coexistence
however the gathering has also
reaffirmed that moscow is not without
friends
lavrov has held several bilateral
meetings most significantly with china's
wangi indonesia had hoped to keep the
focus of its g20 presidency on
post-pandemic economic recovery but the
war in ukraine has overshadowed that
goal
host indonesia has urged g20 countries
to work together to find global
solutions to global challenges jessica
washington al jazeera bali